es un personaje popular y controversial
en irán- el jefe judicial del país
ebrahim raisi se anotó en la carrera por
la presidencia es un destacado clérigo
de línea dura cercano al líder supremo
el ayatolá alí jamenéi y visto como sus
posibles sucesor aunque en 2017 perdió
con hassan rohan y ostenta una base dura
de seguidores una popularidad
ensombrecida por su participación en un
panel involucrado en la ejecución masiva
de miles de prisioneros en 1988 la gente
se está quejando de la situación actual
están enojados su decepción está
creciendo esto debe parar
como su principal rival en la contienda
se asoma al moderado ali larijani este
negociador del acuerdo nuclear de 2015 y
presidente del parlamento hasta 2020
eloy asesor del líder supremo tendrá el
desafío de convencer a los decepcionados
de rohan como siervo necesitamos calma
en nuestra diplomacia para consolidar el
desarrollo económico dentro del país
espero que las negociaciones del acuerdo
nuclear conduzcan a un resultado y eso
le dará a la economía del país la
oportunidad de respirar
la larga lista de aspirantes incluye al
ex presidente ultraconservador mahmud
ahmadineyad y al actual vicepresidente
echa jahangir y representante del
gobierno y esperanza de los moderados
reformistas pero la confirmación de los
candidatos la da el consejo de
guardianes integrado por conservadores
cercanos al ayatolá ali jamenéi se
espera que ese cuerpo vete a los
postulantes reformistas una posibilidad
cuestionada de antemano por el ejecutivo